ja es geht um doping es geht nicht nur
um doping es geht um die frage die mich
sehr bewegt und das jetzt langen langen
jahren nämlich was passiert mit menschen
vor allem die jungen menschen im sport
die instrumentalisiert werden durch
durch dritte ob das nun doping ist oder
ob das auch sexueller missbrauch ist
dann haben wir vor kurzem beschäftigt
und das unter dem aspekt der der
gewinnmaximierung im sport werden kinder
und jugendliche häufig benutzt das ist
mein gefühl und der sport der
leistungssport der hochleistungssport
wird aus meiner sicht nicht unabhängig
kontrolliert und deswegen ist es eben
möglich ein hat voll da alles struktur
wesen über jahrzehnte zu etablieren ohne
dass es wirklich interesse gibt wir auch
mal nachzugeben und das zu kontrollieren
und ich glaube dass wenn wir so
weitermachen dem spitzensport der viele
menschen auf der welt begeistert in
seinen bann zieht dann werden wir
irgendwann erleben dass dieses system
sich selbst abschafft bevor wir darüber
debattieren möchte ich noch ganz kurz
etwas zeigen
ich bin von meinem trainer missbraucht
wurden er hat eigentlich keinen
zeitpunkt ausgelassen um nicht seinen
wünschen und
bedürfnissen freien lauf zu lassen
es ging anfangs los mit anfassen dass er
mich dann immer mehr also systematisch
einmal im erst am anfang einmal im monat
oder also bis hin dann später das ist
dann täglich war zu sexuellen handlungen
genötigt hat
wenn man das sieht bekommt man gänsehaut
das ist ein ausschnitt aus der doku und
das ist ja kein einzelfall
das ist beileibe kein einzelfall und ich
habe am anfang des jahres das ist das
erste mal im allgemeinen berufsjahren
ein film gemacht der nicht mit sport zu
tun hatte da ging es um die katholische
kirche da ging es aber nicht um
missbrauch da ging es um 100 katholiken
und katholiken in deutschland die
schwul-lesbische transgender sind und
die halt gesagt haben sie wollen in der
katholischen kirche arbeiten aber man
hat ihnen fußfesseln quasi angelegt oder
man hat ihm gesagt redet bitte bloß
nicht drüber und natürlich hatte das
alles müsste mit dem missbrauchsskandal
im hintergrund zu tun dass bearbeitet
aber so ein bisschen mit und damals ist
mir schon klar geworden wie schlimm das
ist alleine der kirche und wenn man an
den wirklich skandal denkt dann also
jede mutter muss ja angst kriegen ihre
kinder in die kirche zu schicken aber
leider muss ich inzwischen sagen das ist
eben auch im sport strukturen gibt die
mit weggucken zu tun haben die damit zu
tun haben dass ein system existiert das
vor allem immer ein ziel hat den sport
und die sportart zu schützen und selten
das individuum und weil das halt alles
möglich ist in so eine art für mich ist
fast wie nat schattenwirtschaft duczek
guckt man nicht so genau hin da gibt es
halt darum dass der bund das geld gibt
für die sportverbände damit die olympia
fahren können das ist wichtig und
athleten die halt nicht das bringen was
sie bringen sollten die werden in einem
land wie deutschland hätten und man
hinten fallen runter ich frage mich
immer wir sind deutschland wir sind ein
prosperierendes land vergleichsweise
haben wir es wirklich nötig sich über
goldmedaillen zu definieren oder ist das
eigentlich zumal dieser schwanzvergleich
ist es eigentlich notwendig ich glaube
nein und sie sagen wenn wir uns weniger
darüber definieren würden das ist mehr
das augenmerk als individuum gelegt
werden wir das so einfach alles gar
nicht sagen ich würde eher sagen dass
das wir dass wir einfach erkennen müssen
dass es einfach in einem in einem
gemeinwesen in dem man kultur guten
sport ist für mich ein kulturgut ist ein
stück weit auch mein lebensthema
wenn man das schützen möchten muss dann
kann man es nicht sich selbst überlassen
und dann muss man dafür sorge tragen und
das will der bund ja angeblich und ich
glaube auch das ist jetzt ernster
angefasst wird das thema als noch vor
ein paar jahren auch durch den film
vielleicht ein bisschen initiiert aber
ich finde dass ein gemeinwesen das ja
auch durch den steuerzahler finanziert
wird und nicht zu knapp übrigens das
muss ich auch gefallen lassen dass man
ihm die karten geschenkt und ich finde
das passiert einfach im sport viel zu
wenig und da sind quasi
parallelstrukturen da und das ist nicht
nur im deutschen sport so dass auch
international so wenn man sieht dass wir
beispielsweise beim thema doping was ja
am ende auch nichts anderes ist als eine
andere art des missbrauchs wenn man
nicht jugendliche oder kinder mit
anabolika vollstopft und dabei in kauf
nimmt dass diese kinder oder
jugendlichen damit gesundheitliche
schäden davon tragen mitunter ist das
auch schon so weit gegangen dass sie
gestorben sind daran dann finde ich es
einfach unglaublich wenn man dann halt
immer sagen moment mal leute nur
einzelfälle und das ganze nicht als
strukturproblem begreift und deswegen
glaube ich ist eben ich bin halt quasi
für die berichterstattung über die
schattenseiten des sport zuständig und
mir ist es manchmal schon ein dorn im
auge wenn ich sehe dass wir dieses thema
jedenfalls war es früher so ausblenden
und wenn man ganz ehrlich sind das
bezieht sich jetzt nicht auf deutschland
das sehe ich weltweites phänomen muss
man nüchtern konstatieren dass
olympische spiele auf über den gesamten
erdball jahrzehnte lang übertragen
worden sind und er war ein großer teil
eine übertragung von sportbetrug und es
war nichts anderes und weggeguckt wenn
sie eine dokumentation machen was ich
nicht frage ist was macht das mit ihnen
persönlich also ich hab gerade schon
wirklich schwierigkeiten gehabt diesen
kurzen ausschnitt zu schauen was macht
das mit einem persönlich wenn man diese
dokumentation selber macht
das kann ich so einfach zu beantworten
weil ich bin journalist und ich bin kein
aktivisten und dich ich habe eine
gesunde distanz immer noch zu dem aber
natürlich macht es mich betroffen und es
gab auch schon situationen in meinem
leben auch bei dokus die ich selbst
gemacht habe wo ich würde ich mir selber
angeschaut habe dann angefangen aber
selbst zu weinen weil es mich so
betroffen gemacht hat aber in den
situationen in denen ich dann jemand
interview oder geben gegenüber sitze
dann muss schon sagen aber ist eine
gewisse professionelle distanz
wahrscheinlich wie so ein arzt der thema
operiert der muss ja auch ein bisschen
abstand haben aber unterm strich ist es
schon so dass mich das natürlich bewegt
also das nicht so dass ich bin ja ein
mensch und als mensch ein thema war
immer ich finde ungerechtigkeit ganz
furchtbar ich finde es unerträglich wenn
ich sehe dass menschen benachteiligt
werden und das hat ja am ende auch was
mit fairness zu tun im sport nicht nur
mit gesundheit auch mit fairness und
deswegen kann es mir schon sehr ärgern
wenn ich als feststelle und das habe ich
ja bei russland zum beispiel gemerkt wir
haben diese russland geschichte ja vor
ein paar jahren auf die schiene gebracht
man jetzt den turm stehen da eben erlebt
hat ein händler der ist ja heute auch
ein gebrochener mann so erscheint ist
wenn man sich viele gebrochene menschen
im sport ganz viele und die sieht man
häufig nicht das sind beispielsweise
fälle wurden von menschen die
jahrelang auf dem weg zu in die
internationale spitze waren dann sind
sie plötzlich verletzt dann würden die
sportförderung gestrichen dann kommt ja
sponsor und sagt willig aber nicht sie
auch finde ich immer super wenn ein
sponsor sagt wir sind für fairen sport
wir sind für sauberen sport und wenn man
sich dann fragt wie viel geben die
eigentlich in die nationale anti doping
agentur wir investieren die eigentlich
in die dopingbekämpfung dann stellt man
fest da kommt gar nichts rüber und am
ende geht es immer nur darum dass das
große logo des sponsors bei
fernsehübertragungen großflächig im bild
ist das ist worum es geht und auch dem
spitzensport im deutschen
schwimm-verband oder wem auch immer geht
es vor allem darum
eine eine erfolgsbilanz
prestige chrysler logisch also wenn ich
kann ihnen sagen wie das läuft beim
doping wenn sie wenn sie dopen und
erfolg haben und keiner bekommt es mit
dann profitierte athlet der kriegt
richtig viel asche ja der verdient geld
gekriegt eine goldmedaille
sponsorenverträge kriegt werbeverträge
der kriegt
leistungsprämien weiß ich weiß ja alles
bekommt der manager profitiert davon mit
seiner provision der veranstalter eines
sport die werden zwar da nämlich
prominente athleten im stadion hart
kommen mehr zuschauer und das fernsehen
überträgt und dann können die ihre
werbezeiten besser verkaufen haben hohe
einschaltquoten an sein die werbebanner
wer will dann darüber reden das problem
ist wenn bei doping wie auch in allen
anderen schmuddel themen des sports
solange keiner drüber redet funktioniert
das system und hass der win win
situation wird an der jusos situation in
dem moment in dem plötzlich solche bösen
menschen wie wir um die ecke kommen und
sagen ist weil doch nicht so ganz und
das ist machen naja ich finde ich finde
das schon herausragende arbeit nicht nur
wir übrigens noch andere ja ja mal sagen
übrigens auch die kollegen zdf gehört
auch mal
ist dass ein scheitern auch ein globales
scheitern
gerade der vergleich mit den
katholischen kirche gefallen ist das
sind geschlossene systeme geschlossene
systeme die nach ihren eigenen regeln
funktionieren von außen mischt sich ja
keine ein und die existieren sozusagen
als parallelsystem einer offenen
gesellschaft und und
ich glaube das geht einfach nicht also
es geht nicht dass wir zulassen dass es
solche art von geschlossenen systemen
gibt wo dann die rechte auch der
sportler so himmelschreiend verletzt
werden also gerade jungen leute
natürlich die missbrauch ausgesetzt sind
die vielleicht alles in ihrer karriere
setzen und dann scheitern und nicht
wissen wie es weitergehen soll das kann
man eigentlich nicht machen das sollte
von anfang an viel transparenter sein
diese art der geschlossenheit hast auch
nicht in einer gesellschaft die sich
auch der gerechtigkeit
verstehen ja verschrieben hat und der
der würde des menschen steht bei uns im
grundgesetz das ist doch hier schreit ja
das hat doch mit würde jetzt überhaupt
nichts mehr zu tun leute quasi zu
nötigen sich dopen zu lassen ihren
körper zu schädigen und dann noch den
dem trainer auszuliefern